sixth season for don mattingly running
the miami marlins and he actually goes
up against joe girardi who runs the
phillies but girardi is the one who
actually took the yankees job back in
2008 second place for that job was don
mattingly these two have many
connections of course first on the mound
for the marlins it's the great pablo
lopez you know one of the things that
sticks out he has a tremendous change up
we talked to manager don madeline before
the game and he lo he likes the usage of
the change up he just doesn't want him
to fall in love with it you take a look
at his season that fine era of
2.73 i think more importantly see the
walks the strikeouts is good less hits
than innings pitch and he's one of the
main reasons why 3-2 on its way home
right side that's a fair ball hurry diaz
tossing to lopez got him
beat him by maybe a step roman quinn
never thinks he's out with that
queen is out the box but pablo is late
to dan's point man that was really close
i'm checking that one from joe now it's
brad miller seven for his last 17
starting at second base today and
connecting shallow center field it's
magneris sierra for route number two
and he swings through on the 2-2 pablo
lopez and that change-up
and the opposing pitcher on philadelphia
spencer howard making his second start
of the season coming off an interesting
i would say weird outing on saturday he
has you know his veal he's
started out the game 95 to 97 miles an
hour big strong guy
jammed him gonna be a tough play at
short and the throw is on time ronald
teres with a throw on the run for the
out you can see why right there why the
phillies really like spencer howard
that's a good fastball and a guy that
rojas that can turn on the heater pretty
good this ball eats him up here
dickerson connects deep center and
caught by herrera who made a sick play
yesterday
duval
strikes it left center deep warning
track and off the wall it's played by
quinn and he'll truck into second base
with a stand-up double to lead off the
inning
looked like a first pitch breaking ball
too from spencer howard looked at that
slider and duvall known for hunting a
fastball i think the idea was right this
one just kind of spun this is what duval
has been doing this season and uh i mean
he's been huge for this marlins team
leone deep left
quinn at the track he makes the catch
tagging up his duvall and he's in there
john birdie connects the other way joyce
hustling towards the line and he makes
the catch in stride to retire the side
got him
man
there you see the grip the circle change
up and it gets away with this one here
the intended target was down and away
you can see marshawn sitting down and
away and reaching across his body now
here comes rhys hoskins oh reese hoskins
goes down that one avoided him but just
barely a close call some chin music
taught to turn away from that baseball
just like that
hoskins with a deep drive
left center and he got it that is the
ultimate payback right there is he
saluting the fellas out in the bullpen
gets knocked down two and two
says okay doesn't give up that bet gutsy
at bat rhys hoskins muscles up for his
11th of the year eight of them on the
road and he breaks the ice for the
phillies it's one nothing his second of
the series and he hit that win with
a little added motivation takes one up
up on the chin knocks him down and stays
in and hangs in against a tough righty
herrera is all over that one and it's
into the gap and he's heading for two
and he's in there with a one out double
philly's putting on their hitting shoes
here day game after night game early
start 12-10 start
joyce sends one
center
sierra
has it that should be plenty deep enough
herrera come on down it's two-nothing
phillies on the sac flag from matt joyce
but one thing he has done well talking
about aguilar has been an rbi machine
aguilar lifts it to center
and we'll see what that arm from module
herrera looks like leon not the fastest
it's cut off throw to third is in time
run came across first
so the marlins get one and that will sit
down the side still ranger suarez enters
this game
base is loaded nobody out and allows
just a run this young guy we're watching
right now suarez he could move up in the
pecking order what a heads-up play
gets the lead runner at second with an
excellent throw as he was backing up
towards the line that's about as good a
play as you're going to see that's a
tough play for a lefty because that ball
is taking you away from the mount you
have to spin around and throw
just a quick step throwing a great throw
to the
pretty nice play
and that's weak contact
ground balls
that's what lopez does ground balls
strikeouts on the change up
and he is rolling again
two free tickets today for diaz
solid contact the other way and that
hangs up long enough for quinn great
closing speed again
a center fielder playing left and it
pays off well that's one of the things
when you have speed speed kills
quinn does a great job reading this
right off the bat
marshawn on top and a hot shot gets past
evers into right field and the ball
skips away
marshawn heading to second and he'll
wait there so two miscues although that
was tough to handle for devers but then
trouble in the outfield turns into an
extra base you know and that bird is
still there on the ground take a look at
this scott this ball gets by you're not
lying still there he didn't move he
didn't move bald starts rolling right
towards him and he's like i'm not moving
unfazed
two on for the marlins in the eighth
philly's defense right now they can't
help mr alvarado he can't help himself
cooper's been having some fun in the
season series against philly pitching
cooper on the ground through the right
side deborah's rounding third and he
will score and tie the game at two
garrett cooper off the bench comes
through for the marlins
might be a case of just one too many
fastballs i know that's his bread and
butter pitch but that ball didn't have
much sink on it cliff they were looking
for
something down in the zone oh dubo
herrera is in the cleanup spot for the
second time in his career fresh ball
game in the ninth that one is struck
solidly to right field and it is
off of cooper's glove herrera is heading
for three
and on his horse and in there
head first slide with a lead off triple
in the ninth
oh double herrera powers up big ballpark
holds it but he ends up at third guys
like there's just trying to put the ball
in play
ninth inning action one out marlins tied
up this game in the bottom of the eighth
a comebacker the pitcher who turns
around and gets one at second and
[Applause]
the run scores and the phillies grab the
lead and we want to know if the throw to
first was in time to get to reyes safe
at first run scores john birdie
left side
boom trying to make it two
and they do
game over
billy's take it 3-2
and grab a couple games in a four-game
series they split the series